[Music]
there's no such thing as a perfect City
but to me this city is as close as it
comes that's why we're proud to call
Espanola my home oh our home all
right you got it it's
okay this isn't your typical home
flipping show my homes are reflecting
the local
community and we're husband and wife
this
is look get go
wrun let's grab a quick shot of you um
giving money to that little girl over
there we're doing good here we are good
people thank you we're really good got
it so all I had on me was that $100 bill
no refunds that's not fair come on let
me go get change and what is that that's
nothing this is you don't need to see
this why did you snatch back the money
why didn't you just give her the hun I
was going to buy six of them for $20 I
cursed you what did she
say
what what things have been a little
weird I just need some this thing that
you're doing right now it's helping the
community it's immune to
criticism hi oh margorie can speak to
the work much better than I can I think
I'll let the work speak for
itself
[Music]
just cuz Whitney has a moral issue with
something that's happening we just toss
it
away this doesn't make
sense hi um is everything
okay this is all happening for a
reason I can't wait for this sure to
come
out
everyone will get to see who you really
are
the you know you can tell me anything
right of
[Music]
course
he